this video get more hits than anything i
could ever even dream
look at that that is the littlest that's
a that's just like a a swollen [ __ ]
basically it looks like an acorn look at
that guy this is one of the funniest
things jesus christ i can't put it on
twitter because they'll throw me off
they will throw it they will definitely
this will cancel my twitter subscription
after the balls you think they just left
you on a list oh yeah they're watching
me now
people ratted me up
oh they did when they report you or
something oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] yeah do
they notice notify you that they're
watching or are they just watching
uh you know what
bullet jack is like hitler's nephew
that's right [ __ ]
that [ __ ] video
it's painful but it's hysterical at the
same time
i sent it to some people who just
did not appreciate it
like two people called me back and
they're like joey what the [ __ ]
yeah lee take this [ __ ] over
okay
this podcast is brought to you by next
issue next issue is the mobile app that
lets you tap directly into the world's
most popular magazines anytime anywhere
using your phone or tablet the best part
is next issue is offering a free trial
right now when you go to next issue dot
com slash joey so go to next issue.com
joey they have all your favorite
magazines espn the magazine and they're
full color they're great and they have
some magazines even have bonus video
content go to next issue dot com slash
joey show is also brought to you by
nailed it life.com go to
naileditlife.com use cardboard joey diaz
to get twenty percent off of your first
order and if you live in california they
are also the makers of los gumi shimanos
go to hit ecigs.com that's hit hit
letter e sigs.com
better tasting longer lasting the proof
is in the vape
they have e-cigarettes and e-cigars and
use code word joey's joey's church to
get five for fifty and go to onyx.com
and use code word church to get ten
percent off all of the great
optimization products like alpha brain
new mood shroom tech community tech
support
oh [ __ ]
sunday night
new england covers the spread more ways
than one
october 18th it's monday morning for you
[ __ ] you're starting this week
off with a a [ __ ] bang what
oh [ __ ] black people with [ __ ] bongs
stop it kick it kick it lee
you know i was like in the eighth grade
when this came out how lucky was i
giggling kicking kicking
take this [ __ ] ryan stickers now
[ __ ] tremendous sixth eighth grade
when this came out i remember going to
like other high schools like kick it lee
don't turn this [ __ ] off
i'll [ __ ] stab you
see you're lucky you got this cool in
the gang the cool and the gang i got was
cherish remember that one cherish the
love and all that [ __ ] that's pulling
the gang i got this this is french that
one
was it pulp fiction that brought this
back that's what introduced me to this
cool in the game this is [ __ ]
tremendous i knew the wrong point here
we go hit it take a look
that's [ __ ] tremendous [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] heavy duty ryan sickler lee syed
the church of what's happened now what's
happening gentlemen
had a [ __ ] good weekend how are you
how are you i heard you drove up north
yeah i had a great week someone
started listening to the podcast and and
invited me to their they homeschooled
their kids and they're starting a
podcast studio so i went and set it up
for them it was a lot of fun it was
great they treated me really nice got me
a really nice hotel went out for dinner
your fruit basket yeah forget about it
we don't stop it was great hotel room at
night rubbing your feet
barely i was i was there for like at
most
like 30 hours 36 hours but it was it
blew me away like they're both 13
and it blew me away how much i don't
know that's popular right now and all i
could think about was comedians like do
you guys ever like i'm i'm only
one of my
eight years nine years out of high
school yeah nine years and i'm totally
out of the loop now
do you guys like make it a point to find
out what's
like current and keep like yeah yeah
just at home reading [ __ ]
mechanics and [ __ ] like that
trying to find out what the new trend is
that's what i do all day
i sit around looking for the new hot
[ __ ] thing
lee i know nothing
i'm a [ __ ] half an ape
i know nothing if it wasn't for you i
wouldn't even have a microphone i don't
know nothing
you understand me i don't know what's
going on that's great that you got
exposed to that and that's what ray
canelo said
ray canelo is a friend of the podcast a
kid i grew up with i was an abandoned in
the sixth grade he worked for sci-fi
what was your band's name
uh
you suck
that was the name all right
by the way you gotta hit me up with me
i figured you guys had a good one no we
had no [ __ ] name we were lip-syncing
singing the beatles over [ __ ] music
with the jackson five like
four [ __ ] momos
but my point being he said that he kept
watching his kids watching tv
and it was completely different they
watched television a different way
they watched it on demand or something
and he went to sci-fi and kept telling
them things are changing and sci-fi was
like nah
we're gonna keep doing it so he quit and
he [ __ ] started this youtube channel
for horror people
and he's doing great with it seven
dollars a month unlimited horror he gets
it from all over the world he's been a
horrible buff since we were growing up
that was his thing he went to the movies
in jersey city they tell you and you're
like jesus but he was such a nice guy
and he had such a passion for what he
did
and now he's making a living from just
because he saw the future
so
even as a comic i'm very fortunate you
are too that we're part
of the podcasting i look at a lot of
comics still and go
you don't have a podcast and you're not
part of one
you know right now you're suspect even
if your podcast sucks
you're suspect because you don't have
one people like why wouldn't you have a
[ __ ] podcast everybody has a podcast
at least is trying to put one together
or is a part of one or calls one in if
you're a comedian i'm not talking about
if you're
you know a stock broker working 12 hour
days busting your ass well [ __ ]
[ __ ] like me and making people laugh
you guys work for real you got no
[ __ ] time
it's just crazy how
like how much
competition there's freaking how much
they they have to know now like i was
when i was talking to the to the parents
i i brought up cassius morris and how
he's been doing since he was 10.
and like part of what i was doing up
there was training like the 13 year old
girls
to run the board and do everything that
we're doing and it's just it's and
they're already animating stem and it's
just crazy how much
stuff there is for that for them now and
then and how great like if you started a
podcast like you said you met somebody
this weekend who's been following you
for 15 years if there's a comedian now
who's
16 or 18 and starts a podcast
by the time he gets to be 30 he'll
definitely have people who were there
from the beginning how [ __ ] crazy is
that
i
i got a call from roger paul
maybe 16 years ago roger paul's a
[ __ ] kinky guy and whenever the phone
rings there's always going to be a by
the way
so they want to hire you in milwaukee
i had worked with a guy on a
yoda run
oh wait okay what's a yoda yoda yoda is
a guy in michigan oh yoder okay ten
years ago the father old man yoda 15 20
years ago
if you're a comic and you were from the
midwest
it was them and somebody else but yoda
controlled the midwest whether you were
dirty or clean
if he liked you you covered your nut he
had 63 rooms
and 22 weeks
like all those cities in michigan there
was a comedy club that he booked
that's it and they were all some would
be rooms
some were [ __ ] d rooms some were a
rooms uh
and
he had buffalo he had
cleve i mean he had so many rooms so
i did a yoda run and i met this dude
from milwaukee
and i said what do i got to do to get
into that room and walk in he goes i
recommend you and three months later
some guy calls me and says hey they're
looking for you to see if you want to
work that room
so i went up there in the dead of the
winter uh february valentine's day
weekend like that that weekend
oh my god the [ __ ] the by the way was
the condo
it looked like the monsters
it even had the gate and [ __ ] the whole
[ __ ] deal
oh my god i've talked about this it was
just horrific but anyway
when i was up there that time i met the
lady who actually books that
and she used to book that room at the
time in appleton
she's still around her daughter is now a
booker in that area very small venues
you know colleges [ __ ] like that
so when she offered me the week she said
if you come in tuesday i got a show i do
at marquette
you could do the show 125 bucks one of
those deals you know
so i went and did the show
and in those days all i did was snort
blow and hang out at the store that's it
so my whole comedy routine
was about fiending and looking out
windows and you know
and he nobody was laughing
but i'm not
no i don't remember i don't remember
i don't even listen sometimes i can't
even hear whether people laughing
i knew it wasn't my audience
but now this weekend in minneapolis some
kid pulls me aside from the friday night
early show
it says that he was there that night and
he came to uh
the comedy club that week in the song
see me
and he remembered the girl with the red
hair
and it was just really nice that he was
like i made a mental note i always knew
you would do something it was very nice
that is nice you don't bump into people
like that no
i made a mental note of you
a while ago i mean you you know i've
known you
but i've you know i've always sort of
kept to myself uh we've done several
shows together but there was one we did
the hollywood improv years ago and a
girl went up and she was pretty dirty
and you followed her and you got up and
you said uh that's the type of chick
it'll let your [ __ ] ass pull it out
and suck it and then the crowd went nuts
and you laughed and but that was your
way of saying like i loved her you know
that's what you said out there like i
loved her i loved her dude i laughed so
[ __ ] hard at that for like five
goddamn bits because it's probably 100
true
so funny
my god
that was your just to walk up and say it
off the top of your head and it was so
sometimes trying to break the room up it
was hurt
listen
every unless you're [ __ ] up
you always
if you're you come if you have a little
sarcasm gene
there's things people say
that no matter what age they say it
something comes to your mind and you
want to crack a joke whether it's to
yourself whether it's to the room
whatever the [ __ ] it is you know
uh
today the baby was looking at me she
kept looking at me going blow daddy
blow and i'm like in 20 years you won't
be saying
like you think of things like that yeah
you know
a hot girl goes up on the stage her tits
are out she's talking about getting
[ __ ] in the ass
you're sitting there you're a man even
if you're on a date what are you
thinking about [ __ ] in the ass and
sticking your dick in the mouth
all i'm doing is going on stage and
saying what you're thinking
the reason why i gotta laugh was because
this is as i walked out
this was everybody was [ __ ] thinking
everybody was [ __ ] thinking oh my god
who knows
i hate when comics go up with the set
routine sometimes you have to react to
the [ __ ] room
yeah i agree with you you have to
reproduce
this comedy there's natural comedy in
the room
nothing bothers me more when i see
something coming
there's always even just regular
conversations sometimes
there's a great
comedic banter in a conversation energy
that
somebody else might not be laughing but
you might even feel that oh yeah all the
time a little comedy light banter that
you're like oh my god that's so
that thing in a movie was such a
brilliant conversation they had
you know we're so as people say that's
the stuff that makes me laugh most that
you say now because i i'll come and see
shows a lot so i'll get to know some
bits but the stuff that makes me laugh
is this stuff that you just say that
you'll never say again yeah that's the
those are my favorite people in the
world like my grandmother and her
sisters were the same way i couldn't
wait to hear what like you know we've
all been through situations but i
couldn't wait to hear their response
to that situation you know i mean much
like what he's saying with you like
you want to hear what you're going to
say next people really enjoy uh you know
the whatever it is behind it uh the the
sarcasm the smart ass-ness the
the the funny uh the clever you know
because the other thing too is as
comedians
we say what people are thinking but we i
think it's our job to say that same
thing in a way
they've never thought of saying that
does that make sense yes yeah it makes a
lot of sense so it's 100 relatable but
maybe you picked the right word here or
you know chose it to say it this way
instead
uh and so it still hits home but it's
like wow because i you know i think it's
our job to to write beyond that i think
if someone pays you to see that if i'm
going to relate to you i should be able
to say it to you in a way maybe you
hadn't thought about saying it but you
get my point exactly
that makes sense
absolutely you're freaking me out
you look good too joey diaz so do you
everybody's looking good lisa i got some
son to woman [ __ ]
this weekend up there in the southern
resort whatever the [ __ ] you were
i had a good time in minneapolis that's
a great little [ __ ] room man i hear
yeah they're super nice people
i guess some some guy gave me maple
syrup and rice
and then he wrote me a note but he
didn't write me his [ __ ] name i can't
even give him a [ __ ] shout out
he gave you syrup and rice was it was it
cooked rice or was it in your bag in a
bag to cook it then some other guy gave
me two hits acid
people ask me if i want to do math
that's a crazy [ __ ] you guys are
going to send me to the right i lost the
ass in the crazy house in my wallet
somewhere i don't know what i did with
it oh my god i'll bump into that someday
when you're in an airport stuck you
stick your hand in one of your
compartments and there it is a hit of
ass and you got a nine-hour stop
and you got some e-cigs you got a vapor
pen [ __ ] it you go for broke jack i told
you i look here it is i i smoke weed
obviously but drugs have always they've
always scared me for me but in the right
situation what's the worst drug you've
ever done
uh
i mean outside of weed the only two
drugs i've ever done are shrooms one
time and i did uh ecstasy like twice
what did you think the first time it
didn't work the second time a girlfriend
i was dating from argentina gave me that
we [ __ ] we went and rented a cabin up in
big bear that was the one of the
greatest nights of my life i mean it was
i i'm how long were you high for oh
hours six five hours maybe and i mean
i understood finally because everyone
kept describing to me what it did and
how it felt and finally when i felt that
permanent smile get plastered on my face
i was like oh this is what it is and it
was just that was a lot of fun but
shrooms to me
i enjoyed that [ __ ] for like
45 minutes and then i was just like all
right i want this
enough get it out of me get it out of me
you know i always
if i ever
i don't know most of the time i don't
get high
i just
you know
smoke
and i relax and then you just dissipate
and float out of it but with shrooms
that [ __ ] just hung around and i wanted
it to be over i was like enough of this
last sunday we did ahead of acid on the
show and it was uh
pretty intense it got pretty intensive
moments it was and it was fun
and
i had to leave because if not we would
have stayed here till six in the morning
like that's how you feed an acid trip is
with people talking conversation and
smoking weed
i don't know if i could have gone out
publicly like i used to
you could go out publicly on acid when i
was 16 where did you go
i didn't have a house i didn't i i lived
with some people but i couldn't stay in
and watch tv with them
and do ahead of acid so you met for your
friends
and you took ahead of ass at 7 30.
that meant by 11 you're burned you are
burning how old are you
16 and 17
and you're behind the high school look i
would have come with you but i would
have been scared to death
we'd get in those days you bought 25
dollars got you like 30 joints
so you rolled them up you rolled up 30
joints before you went out so everybody
knew where they stood
like we're not going home do we smoke
dirty [ __ ] joints like that's crazy
and sometimes we'd smoke 25 and we each
take a joint home
for the morning
you know like that we were tight
but that was it but we went out until
four or five in the morning
when you trip your [ __ ] balls i don't
think i'd like that walking around or
we do what we did the other night and go
to the midnight movie
that's a blast it's not you don't freak
out sitting in a movie theater no in
fact you can you even concentrate on the
movie yes the movie sucks you in okay
the colors are brighter at least that's
right yeah at one point the movie just
sucked in at first you'll be like i
wouldn't take leave to see like the
rocky horror picture show oh that was
terrible because i'd kick him i couldn't
side stab him while he was sitting there
and go crazy i need to [ __ ] out of here
i feel like you'd kill people at the
rocky horror movie yeah like i went once
and they got so excited
they were like jumping up in their seats
a girl broke up with me over not going
to rocky
we weren't even boyfriend girlfriend
well were you i was 19 she was 27.
she was my neighbor she was an italian
girl from milwaukee and she had a sister
tia mia
something and she used to cut my hair
man
i was a 19 year old kid i just moved
from jersey
to basalt colorado
holland hills i'm living in holland
hills in the house
with
four [ __ ] bedrooms and three guys
that are [ __ ] each bench pressing 480
you know
one of them went back to live uh his mom
had a heart attack so he left
and the one guy that was a garbage man
he was a garbage man and aspen and he'd
come home every night with skis and [ __ ]
like that
it was a pretty bizarre time i was a
young kid i was fresh out of new york
everything i looked at had a price tag
you know i was a shark man i was a
[ __ ] shark but these girls lived next
door to me
and they were very nice they'd come over
and they'd make dip and
and they were like green bay packer fans
and we'd watch football and blah blah
blah
and the girl said you know i cut hair
the older one is like i cut it out
so i went over there one day and she's
cutting my hair blah blah okay
and then you know it just went we were
just friends and and then sometimes i
would go to her way she worked at a wine
shop called the grog shop i still
remember and i would meet her and she
would give me a ride what's called down
valley
like if you work in aspen you have to go
down valley you have to go past snow
mass
pass old snow mass into basalt and woody
creek and all that [ __ ]
so
you know we would just flirt
we just flirt and one night i asked her
black blatantly
blatantly i said she goes what's your
ice oh she was cutting my hair and i put
my hand under her skirt
and she goes what's your problem and i
go i like you i got a crush on you she
goes just say so
just don't put your hand under my skirt
that's not gentleman in life she goes
what do you want to do you want to take
me on a date you just want to [ __ ] just
tell me your intentions it was that
blatant
like it was that blatant and i go i
really don't know i just i don't know i
thought i'd take it to a movie or
something and she goes i'll date you but
you got to move by the next door
she goes i can't date a neighbor it'll
never happen
and i was moving anyway we were moving
at the end of the month
so i waited till july first
and i hitchhiked down here this is the
savage i am yeah i [ __ ] hitchhiked
down there at 10 o'clock at night
and i just knocked on her screen door
and she's like what are you doing here
go i moved out
i'm ready for our date what do you want
to do and she goes come on in and i
think we did a little blow her sister
was there the sister was really nice we
talked for a little while
and then she took me upstairs and i
think we stayed up all night and did
dirty stuff and
and she drove me home the next day and
it was like she was all you know she was
older but i remember the first time my
roommate in snowmass caught me with it
because she would go to work five to
twelve or five to ten so she would come
up in the afternoons and my buddy would
be you know working but he knew her from
the building we all lived together next
door and i just never told them that i
was with nobody's business
she came up one afternoon with brie
cheese that's the first time i ever ate
brie cheese and an apple dog i'm an
american cheese type of guy at that time
i had only tasted american and swiss
cheese
and that was all
and she showed parmesan
she showed up with brie [ __ ] cheese
and an apple and she smeared it on the
apple and i'm like are you [ __ ] crazy
i'm from jersey
and she's like eat that and i'm like no
we got into like an argument i wouldn't
eat [ __ ] preach are you [ __ ] crazy
it looks like pimple juice get that [ __ ]
away from me it smells funny you want to
bring me [ __ ] cheese you bring me
american cheese american cheese
story she tells me oh my god i gave this
guy who wouldn't even read dog i was
fresh out of [ __ ] jersey do you
understand me
well you you need her brie cheese and
you wouldn't go to rocky i didn't know i
wouldn't need her [ __ ] nothing and
then she still dated me we would hook up
once a week
and just eat something and have sex and
stay up all night sometimes we did blow
sometimes we didn't it wasn't about that
it was just she was like older than me
and stuff i don't know what it was
and then one i didn't see her for a
couple days
and she called at that time i didn't
have a [ __ ] phone we didn't even have
a phone
she would have to call somebody and they
would give me a message
and i called her back at the liquor
store and she goes yeah i want you to
meet my friends at the rocky horror and
it was like halloween time of the year
she goes i want you to dress up again
i'm from jersey dog papa don't dress up
to go to the movies i show up with
shorts and a football jersey i was crazy
then you know
i didn't have a duffel bag you know what
i did no toilet paper to throw i didn't
have a duffel bag i had a pillow bag
that i used in those days
there was no backpacks
there was no backpacks 19 yellow case i
had a pillow case i put my t-shirts and
my books and i go to town pillowcase
like i ran away from home
i was a [ __ ] i was primitive
in 1984 83 i already learned i was
primitive if you did anything with me
you basically took your life into your
own hands in those days can you explain
who's picking up my 19 year old joey
diaz with all of his clothes in a
[ __ ] pillowcase
27 year old hairdresser and aspen
colorado they used to have a place
called the hitching post
and if you live down valley in the early
80s
you had signals
so people would look at you and go like
this this meant a short way
if you went like that
they would pull over and pick you up
it was called the hitching post and
people that didn't want to drive down
valley by themselves would pick you up
bro
and there was never no beefs it was nice
people i never got picked up by no in
fact don henley picked me up from the
come on
don henley picked me up from the eagles
one time
number four to july 1983 john denver
picked me up going up the hill to
snowmass village yes he did in a [ __ ]
jeep with an eagle on it yes he did
to do his benefit i swear to my [ __ ]
daughter's eyes dawg i gotta that's a
little love for john that's how [ __ ]
lit that's how cool
that time was in my life hold on i was
tell me about don henley like he pulls
over don henley pulls over in the truck
okay
now from the minute i hit
snowman's village i'm hearing all these
rumors
i'm hearing that jack nicholson lives in
maroon bells which he did
i'm hearing that clint eastwood hangs
out at the holiday inn at the airport
in those days it was a little holiday
inn at the airport and i heard clint
eastwood was there four nights of
[ __ ] week
at that time hunter s thompson hung out
at the woody creek tavern
six nights a week
and there were rumors
that people would go visit them i didn't
know anything about anything
there were rumors that the eagles half
of them lived in aspen
there was rumors that
another band that was cousins to the
eagles the
knitty diddy gert bands oh yeah nitty
gritty dirtbag they were cousins to the
eagles in fact towards the end of my
electrician career i hung
i hung fixtures at the guy's house
from the nitty ditty grip band
okay
so yeah there was all these rumblings
of these people that were in town there
was also rumblings of people who came to
visit you know charles bronson [ __ ] like
that so
here i am a young [ __ ] kid
didn't know i wanted to get in the
entertainment business but was a huge
fan of movies
and i'm bumping into people
so i'm hitchhiking
i'm minding my own [ __ ] tonight's day
no it's two in the afternoon
july afternoon i'm hitchhiking i'm
living in colorado maybe
three months four months at the time i'm
living in snowmass village
i get in the [ __ ] truck
how you doing what's happening what's
your name blah blah blah
i don't even know if we discuss names i
just know that after about five minutes
i kept looking at this [ __ ]
and he looked familiar to me but he had
sunglasses on and a baseball hat
so i don't say nothing you know
and we're talking and i'm like you're in
construction yeah blah blah blah i mean
because he had a big thick checkbook
remember in the old days yeah yeah you
had a business you had a big checkbook
it looked like a [ __ ] notebook yeah
and he had a bunch of postcards on there
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah this is a
25 minute ride in those days
a beautiful scenic ride you had to pass
this this [ __ ] diner
if you went down this big popular street
in aspen you had to
pass this little diner the something
house the hickory house oh my godly
their specialty was the pound cake
though the crumb cake how'd they do with
a stick of butter melting on top of it
like not a [ __ ] piece of margarine
not low fat butter gluten free a [ __ ]
stick like a quarter stick melting on
top of this bun you would slice it the
butter would go into the middle i can't
describe it there i would stop in there
just for the [ __ ] uh
whatever the [ __ ] it was
you boom and then we we stuck on and
wait don henley took it in no we didn't
i had gone there before
you have to pass this i'm just it's
coming back to me as i'm telling you the
story and i make that right and then you
hit back and you make a left and you're
back on that that it's like a little
thing a turn
and by then i kept thinking to myself
i've seen this guy before
i've seen this [ __ ] before i
just don't know where
i just can't put my [ __ ] finger on it
and i don't know if you guys remember
you're too young and you're way too
young
and 83 was this big year you know
boys of summer
yeah boys of summer hit him with that
end of the year
no no this is way before that this was
like his first solo thing but one of the
song videos he did he did in the
classroom
okay
don henley he did in the classroom where
he was a teacher
and
that i'm going this is the [ __ ] guy
now you want me to lie to you and tell
you i knew don henley was from the
eagles at that i couldn't put it all
together i'm just trying to figure out
where the [ __ ] i know this guy from
and the next thing you know i go i know
you i know you i know you
and he finally just breaks down and he
goes yeah okay
i'm don henley i'm the singer from the
eagles do you live in town and i don't
know what he said i mean it was like a
five-minute conversation
and he hope i go can you do me a big
favor i have a friend that's a huge fan
of the eagles
he went to see you under whatever tour
can you sign something for me there was
no pictures in those days
and he took a postcard
that had his address he ripped the
address and he left d.o.n and he wrote
over it from my friend and i mailed it
to him that's nice it was don [ __ ]
henley
and this but this was after
uh john whatever john denver john denver
picked me up i moved to snowmass village
july 1st
1983
and the third i moved in on a [ __ ]
wednesday how was the weather the
weather it was july it was still cool at
night it was beautiful snowmass village
snowmass village is two point something
miles up a mountain
so once you're up that mountain you're
up that mountain
okay so what people usually do is they
drop you off at the bottom of snowmass
and they go down straight
down valley to basalt and glenwood
springs and that type of stuff you have
to cross 82 which is one of the worst
roads in the country especially after
october you don't want to [ __ ] around
82. more [ __ ] debts on 82 than
anywhere in the country you cross the
street and then people are making a left
up the hill the snowmass pick you up
i'm standing out there one in the
afternoon like a [ __ ] momo i had just
moved to snowmass
i went out the night before and got
[ __ ] up with jimmy burkle god bless
his soul
we got [ __ ]
up
and i remember i lived at either d12 or
c12 and i knocked on a building c12
and some guy answered can i help you i'm
like oh my god i'm sorry i got the wrong
door i just moved here he was from
[ __ ] new york city and we became
friends his name was bergy
from that encounter me knocking on the
door one in the morning coked up out of
my [ __ ] mind
he came out you're all right though let
me get you a beer he got me a beer and
he walked me and he walked me to my door
and i'll catch you tomorrow and i look i
never forgot his name bernie bergie from
new york city from like [ __ ] 154th
street my family's irish
i hate [ __ ] weekends that's why i
moved out here i hope you're not a
[ __ ] puerto rican that's he used to
always tell me i'm happy you're not a
puerto rican i'm happy you're not
so that's when john denver picked me up
in the afternoon like at one o'clock
doug i got in that [ __ ] jeep and i
couldn't believe it was john [ __ ]
denver i'm like oh my god
but there was no cameras i didn't hug
them nothing i didn't know
picture the tweet and all that [ __ ]
i know man
i ran into uh
i ran into mick fleetwood from fleetwood
mac at a bagel joint in the valley in
sherman oaks and he was sitting in there
with i can only assume it was a manager
or some business representative in some
aspect but
i just walked over to him to go
mick fleetwood he's like yeah i got i
just wanted to shake his hand i couldn't
believe i saw mick fleetwood just
sitting and chilling in this little tiny
corner
bumped into giza butler the chinese oh
yeah
he said he knew it was geezy he wanted
to say something to him but he didn't
want to bother him
i took right before i moved here i took
my younger brother to see bb king our
dad introduced us to bb king and we just
became huge bb king fans and he's at
a blues festival at the u.s naval
academy in annapolis maryland so we're
driving down
uh the two of us borrow we borrow a
friend's mitsubishi eclipse and we drive
down what year uh this is probably
93
my dad had that eclipse i think
so uh
i take my brothers it's like right
before i move here it's gonna be a
a moment you know together my younger
brother
so we're in the parking lot of the naval
academy and we are
just cheech and chong in this [ __ ]
car we are blazing the [ __ ] out of this
thing it's not our car so we also think
it's funny that we're smoking the [ __ ]
out of this this car that's a friend of
ours we get out and i mean it's
definitely smokey around there we're in
such good spirits we walk in there's a
bb king poster like this one right here
and
it's like seven bucks i just i remember
thinking god that's that's awfully cheap
for a concert poster and it was him as a
young kid
so i buy it and i look at my brother and
i'm like i'm gonna get this signed by
b.b king before we leave this show
tonight we get in it's eda james and
it's jay giles and it's jimmy vaughn
and i see where they're coming in and
leaving so my brother and i go over
there and right as bb king is done he's
walking by and he shakes my hand and
then i i'm trying to give him the poster
he keeps going so i give it to the
trumpet player i'm like hey can you do
you mind getting bb to sign this for me
and he didn't hear me say bb so he
starts signing i'm like this
motherfucker's ruining my poster
but i didn't have a heart to tell him
you know like i assume not you man i
want bb king to sign this [ __ ]
that's terrible so we go outside my
brother's laughing at me and [ __ ] did
you replace the poster well i see one of
the band members talking to this chick
he's macking on this girl and i walk up
to him hey man look i just want to get
this [ __ ] thing signed he's like just
go inside this door right here there's
people waiting to meet bibi
uh and just get in line and i was like
don't don't don't don't arrest me he's
like no they won't they will not they'll
just ask you to leave that's the most
that'll happen to you i said all right
[ __ ] it and i just interned at college
for radio station so i knew how to get
in there and act like i belonged there
and that's exactly what the [ __ ] i did
my brother was scared he's like i'm not
coming i said well stay here so i get in
line i start chatting all these people
up like i've been with them all night
you know what i mean
and uh i'm standing next to jimmy
vaughn's dressing room door and bb king
and said on stage it was his birthday
the next day well now it's after
midnight
so we get in my plan is i'm gonna i'm
gonna say happy birthday i'm gonna try
to be the first one to wish him whatever
it was happy 83rd birthday lady opens
the door and he's sitting in there and
i'm just like i was blown away because
i'm a huge hendrix freak i love stevie
ray vaughan this guy has played with
everybody from youtube to everybody
so i see him and i'm like happy birthday
bb he's like oh the first one i was like
oh i was all so excited so he's the
nicest dude he sits and he'll he won't
say no to an autograph well there's
these two white dudes in there that
bring in like i'm not kidding a hundred
albums
and he's signing and he's saying things
like man you got a lot of stuff here you
know and i
at some point i just felt like he was
waiting for someone to speak up
and i just said man you got a lot going
on up there and he's like all right
that's enough people complaining i was
like oh boom so he thanked me he signs
my poster and he's got little uh index
card pictures of himself up there and i
had him just sign one for my younger
brother so i'm back there for i met two
of his daughters i'm hanging out with
him talking to him about hendrix i'm
talking to him about stevie ray vaughan
and and then i leave i'm back there for
like an hour my brother's like where the
[ __ ] were you like he's like i thought
you were arrested i was like nah man i
said look at this and i opened it up
he's like you gotta be [ __ ] kidding
me i was like i told you i was getting
bb king to sign this so we start driving
home in the eclipse and we're talking
about it and [ __ ] and i'm telling them
that story and then i busted out the
little picture i said i got there for
you right there he was so jazzed he
still got it framed up in his house and
right now in maryland he must be pissed
he didn't hang out with bbc i told him i
was like all you had to do was follow me
dude
but i met him yeah that was it was a
good one
i was always scared as a kid to go
backstage at all concerts
i always felt intimidated i was in my
20s i was yeah i was what i thought was
going to happen i never even
the thought never even crossed my mind
all those concerts i went to before i
met you i was if you were on the local
news i was star struck by you like if
you like if you want
i worked at the framingham amc and i
think a dude from espn came in and i
almost hit my pants like that like that
stuff used to really i usually get
really nervous
no i don't think
i ever got jazzed up i got jazzed up
when i saw basketball players yeah when
i was a kid when i saw bernard king i
almost here
i was that way with um eddie murray from
the orioles man that was even before
ripken eddie was there and we would go
to games with my dad and eddie was just
he was the [ __ ] he was my first like
oriole love
and my whole life i've loved eddie
murray and just a couple years ago i'm
flying back to baltimore out of lax i'm
on southwest and i look over and there's
eddie murray sitting there and i get
like i don't give a [ __ ] about much i
got excited i was like oh my like the 10
year old me was like holy [ __ ] that
[ __ ] eddie mark
so i go walk over and sit next to him
and this dad sits down next to him with
this kid and i'm like god damn it
eddie's talking to him for a while and
he's on another airline right next to it
also going to baltimore
finally that dad leaves and i sit down
next to him and quickly like i'm like oh
what the [ __ ] am i what's my opening
line to eddie murray like i didn't
really know what to say and he just
looked at me and i looked at myself
what's up 33 and he started laughing and
we talked
crabs he loves crabs he was going back
for the orioles they were doing a statue
of him and all this [ __ ] at the camden
yards and i just got to sit and talk to
him about i was like you're my favorite
oriole he's like knock out i go cow's
right behind you but you know you were
there first like you're my first [ __ ]
oreo i thanked him for everything he did
for the city he was a good dude man i
was that one got me excited and then i
land in baltimore i go right to this
restaurant to eat crabs
and eddie murray is pulling out of the
parking lot he just got there before me
and had him and bounced so we were on
point with that making me [ __ ] hungry
you know what happened to me this
weekend talking about eddie murray
i was in my hotel room i walked around
the mall you know sometimes you just put
the tv on and you just take your
notebook out and you make notes and you
scroll a little bit and
you watch college football game for
three minutes and it was the beginning
of uh
i mean i caught it right from the
beginning of uh beverly hills cop yeah
and it [ __ ] sucked me in
and uh
when the kid gets killed
and he's outside arguing with the cop
and all that like that movie
for me was [ __ ] huge
like i was watching them like i dragged
my best i i go george
you have to come see this morning he's
like well i got a date and i go i don't
give a [ __ ] we're going right now we
walked over the [ __ ] george
washington bridge
and i took him to harlem stone to see
beverly hills cop the two biggest movies
at that time were belly hills cop and
rambo
the beverly hills cop was [ __ ] huge
and last week we were talking about
movies that stood that time beverly
hills cotton when he goes to a
restaurant
and he says he wants to talk to the guy
he goes i went to the doctor and he said
i got herpes simplex 3. i want to talk
to the man before things start falling
off
he [ __ ] uh
eddie murphy was a bad [ __ ] but
there was a moment there i had a little
nervous breakdown
like i was like this was
so long like this movie was the
beginning of my freedom
like i i went to see this movie and i
left jersey a month later like this was
this got me this movie for some reason
or another
whether
i didn't know i was getting into the
comedy business but for some reason
watching that movie gave me a little bit
of hope i don't know why i don't know
why i don't even know if you understand
what the [ __ ] i'm saying i understand
yeah maybe it was just i don't know it
just gave me what about it
what what about i gave you hope
well the [ __ ] scene with a friend
gets killed that was me
in those days i was your best friend i
disappeared when i come back to say hey
man what's happening oh yeah let me take
you out for dinner let me stay with you
for two days okay there was always a by
the way
there was always a by the way i had just
robbed somebody i got somebody's coke
that coke gets snoring with me and
having a good time at three in the
morning i go listen i gotta tell you a
story
you know and now you're in there you are
sitting i'm in your living room
you just did an ounce of my coke that we
just robbed from pete the killer
and here you are sitting there going
you're dropping this on me now at three
in the morning it's terrible so i'm an
accessory right now
somebody could kick my door in right now
and shoot you you give her being a nice
guy yeah i believe that was me that was
me that was who i was i uh can i
use the restroom yeah yeah do what you
got to do in fact put on some [ __ ] uh
tony bennett [ __ ] what happened
you drank water and soda staying
hydrated
oh yeah you got to stay dry
what the [ __ ] the word is you know
kick it out play a little tony bennett
[ __ ]
it's monday morning you bad
[ __ ] grab your balls
it's gonna be a good week halloween's
next week
i wanna be around
to
pick up the pieces
when
somebody breaks your heart
some
somebody
twice as smart
as you wanna go to salami tomorrow
what's the questions there's no
questions you always got to tell me you
got [ __ ] to do tomorrow
i'm trying to work on this special name
i'm trying it's hard when we do 3pm
podcast and get
stoned out of our minds and we we wanted
to do our jiu-jitsu's earlier
is that what you're trying to [ __ ]
tommy cox smoking how was your weekend
you had a good weekend i had a great one
today you went to sushi with paul yeah
to celebrate and would you
eat the mussels
no we uh we've got a couple rolls got a
bunch of just like tuna sushi
but it's like
it was 28 i think because all you can
eat 28 a piece they give you an hour
they make sure you eat the rice they
don't want no problems
oh they really watch you know do they
really those japanese people don't [ __ ]
around the waitress i was there two
weeks ago three weeks ago it's pretty
good i went in there one day
it's okay you could get sick in there
that borderline
they give you the fish that's just about
to go bad the next day
you eat it i just have weird stuff man i
got like shrimp i keep it light too the
salmon
the salmon is what i like i always go to
get salmon right
i judge a place by its salmon and the
salmon there they do something to it
it's not bad i didn't get sick
is it is it long i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on who's out there
these people [ __ ]
they gotta pee and [ __ ]
come on in here [ __ ] sucker
smells good that candle works
you know what
that's a great candle it's funny i
thought about you the other day joey
because you used to say you get would
get sushi when you were trying to eat
healthy
even when you were like really big like
4 15. and right before we were going to
do the ass i was like i should get sushi
to be like nothing but i'm going to do
acid
it was that was them in the back of my
mind if i ate fish the next day and
drank water i was healthy my system was
clean of the cocaine and i was saying
it's [ __ ] over
now we're taught it was i
that's what i got out of the acid trip
i'll tell you the azure trip was fun
last week you giggled
i don't think i want to do it again i'm
going to tell you what
when i went home that night
i'm sitting there on the chair and i'm
eating i get home and there's a cuban
steak sandwich and i inhale that
[ __ ] cold not even in the
microwave the bread was harder than [ __ ]
just to kill the acid just to you know
we'll will filling your uh stomach up
that'll sometimes yeah sometimes i had
like four or five stars we also had
edibles
so yeah we went 500 600 milligrams deep
by the edibles and the [ __ ] ass
you got to eat something to tame it down
i don't that could have taken the
[ __ ] in one shot
so uh
i'm sitting there man i gotta tell you
what dawned on me
if you go to my house and you sit down
there's there's a
you know the tv's there and [ __ ] and
there's a desk and this stupid [ __ ]
but there's a picture that sticks out in
that wall it's a picture of the baby
it's like a wanted picture
she was pissed she didn't really want to
[ __ ] take the picture
and just something about her face every
night while i'm watching tv it just
catches me and i shake my head like i
can't believe that's my [ __ ] dog
yeah
every [ __ ] night i try to watch tv
and sometimes i go out and balcony and i
get high and i'm just trying to soothe
down you know i drink a cup of coffee or
something just to calm me down and every
eight minutes i'll look at that [ __ ]
picture
and i started looking at that picture
i'm like jesus christ
i can't believe i did acid tonight
you know
i goof around with lee i lovely that
that you know i always call leonardo lee
i got heroin tonight i got opium
i got [ __ ] gorilla biscuits
[ __ ] i'm gonna uber and i got nothing
but edibles you know but i'm just
torturing you well
but then the hash you said we had opium
that night and i had no idea what that
cuz that hatch was different than the
regular hat oh yeah i showed you
something actually i might have had one
i got the one-eyed jew dawg this
[ __ ] works with isis
what do you think he's smoking do you
think he's smoking regular [ __ ] he's
smoking [ __ ] the [ __ ] that sets the
government off
so anyway it's really weird like
i talk about all this crazy like i'm
very thankful we did not do two bits of
acid off the bat last week
i'm telling you right now that acid we
would have been [ __ ] up till tuesday
when ari laid on the floor it was just
different things
that acid was really good i want to
thank what's his name he knows what his
name is you know i love you
that asset was really [ __ ] strong for
me it was it had been years there was a
point here for two hours i was gone
when we were at the front when you say
gum tell me
where what do you where are you gone
yeah like giggles had taken over okay i
was baseline i was borderline about i
was seeing little things i wasn't seeing
are you present mentally can you have a
conversation oh yeah he's good
but you're just laughing your ass yeah
i'm very experienced in that [ __ ]
because i know you can tame it yeah
you could tame it unless they look at
you and your eyes are pinned
they won't know
and you have to know how to juggle
people get them out of the way and then
look at that person that you're with
that trip yeah the whole thing about the
action
is the four or five people you're with
and you set them loose in the bar and
that's where the fun time is and
everybody gets their bag on and then you
all connect they're gonna three when the
bar closes oh my god and you go eat and
everybody's sitting there going oh yeah
this acid wore off yeah yeah this
[ __ ] world because it plays with your
emotions
and next you know you're laughing at the
[ __ ] waitress
the cheeseburger is funny the french
fries look funny the cook's wearing a
[ __ ] french hat like everything that
can happen
everything that could happen is it's
like i can't believe this is [ __ ]
happening
i cannot believe this and that's what
ahri should do next time is get nine
guys get them ahead of acid and set them
looser cameras and they gotta talk about
this is not happening
this is not really [ __ ] happening so
i went home and i'll tell you what i
thought about and you're gonna relate to
this
my dad died
one of the things i never really talk
about him at all
he's like a forgotten soldier in my life
i think about him because i do not
remember him
i remember stories and in my mind
there's a situation i remember i was
driving with him in the car how old how
were you when he passed three oh yeah
okay so i don't remember this [ __ ]
guy
and it drove me crazy my mom said for
years every time the door would open i
would look at the door and she would
feel really bad inside and stuff she was
like it was like he was coming home and
i couldn't describe it to you when
you're three you can't explain to
somebody that somebody's [ __ ] dead
she goes i tried to break it into you
know he had gone to the stars you know
he'd gone to god's house
el cielo as they call it whatever the
[ __ ] it is so
it always [ __ ] with me you know and i
always thought about one thing like
for years i was mad at him because his
his death was drug related
and i always said to myself what was he
thinking
what was he thinking this is what i was
thinking of this [ __ ] acid trip at 1
30 in the morning i got tv on but i'm
not really watching the tv your
daughter's picture took you there first
took me there first i'm thinking about
like
how the podcast is doing well now you
know we're all having a great time you
know what i'm saying yeah we smoke pot
yeah we eat at the bus we'll give us a
[ __ ] dog
you [ __ ] wake up you do 10x 10
jumping jacks you have an egg and the
edible's gone you know what i'm saying
nobody gets hurt nobody you know i'm
saying nobody gets up in the morning and
calls you and say joey i need 10 models
edibles right yeah right
nobody nobody you know you know you do
blow with somebody until six in the
morning they wake up that coke is good
they'll call you i'm coming over there
right now you're like wow
how [ __ ] crazy this guy woke up and
this is what was on his mind already
that was bizarre i never wanted to be
that guy but
i'm sitting there going you know me and
lee [ __ ] around and
i taught chili and
it would be fun to do a line of chinese
heroin it would really be fun to come
here on a sunday night
and get a little brown little chunk of
heroin and just do a little taste i'm
not doing heroin you know listen lee
shut the [ __ ] up
get the [ __ ] up your family at this
point you're not gonna do everyone
but
what's going on in our lives right now
this is when you die
it's like len bias he got drafted oh
you're breaking back he was a [ __ ]
boston celtic he sure was and all of a
sudden he's [ __ ] dead and you sit
there and go this is a shameless debt
even that acid deal like that asset was
[ __ ] strong jack i get in the [ __ ]
car i make a left turn
i said i get caught in somebody's
headlight that's what happens with acid
you get caught in somebody's headlight
and all of a sudden you're hitting a
[ __ ] tree we need that in our lives
right now we're having a great time
right now in our lives
i'd love to do ndma and all that [ __ ]
and do it on the show again you know
that was crazy the acid last week and
that's what came to my mind like
if i did an acid what if i did two of
those that night and my heart [ __ ] i
had a heart attack in my sleep like
rowdy roddy piper because i'll [ __ ]
go to sleep and you know your heart
keeps [ __ ] beating i've done acid and
all these people i could drink 20 red
bulls and go to bed and i could feel my
heart pounding as i'm falling
i could feel it pounding i've done it a
thousand times on cocaine and [ __ ] like
that
you know i would hate not to wake up and
for somebody to say lee what the [ __ ]
were you guys thinking last night how
can he's an old man joe diaz how can you
do acid i need that on lee's conscience
you know what i'm good i'm good with the
weed and i'm good with the [ __ ]
edibles that's me man that's the i'm
good i'm good this is this is what's
always scaring me i you know i'm from
maryland and i remember i was on my way
to the dentist with my father when we
were listening to the radio and they
announced lembias was dead from cocaine
overdose and we were just like blown
away i'm still blown away by that i'm
still blown away by that and
that was
like stuff like that and and also we
have a cousin who's a paranoid
schizophrenic this guy's
you know admittedly done every drug that
there could be done since he's been like
16 dude he's i'll tell you and that's
the other thing that they always well in
the shower tonight i was thinking about
when i was a kid and you and when you
first like thought about doing acid like
you went to some neighborhood guy that
was a little [ __ ] up you're like
so tell me about asthma it's like oh the
trip it's psychedelic the hindus
jimmy page this and this but then he
goes you know at one point one day you
you threw a hit and asked you don't come
back
that's what i needed my life like sid
barrett to take a hit ass that's exactly
my cousin and it throws my yeah that's
weird that's what happens you would just
stay like high on acid you just don't
come back you don't come back he he was
a great lacrosse player he was being
looked at by hopkins he was an athlete
he was a black belt in karate spill to
put his foot through a watermelon and he
kept taking acid
and he never came back from the game he
didn't and he'll he's he's
a watermelon he used to put his foot
through a watermelon man
he's a badass he's so [ __ ] deep on
some acid
you could go really let me tell you
where he is now now and so
him and and lem bias and [ __ ] like
that's always the reason i was always
like i feel like i'm a candidate for
first time use if it really was their
first time used dead that [ __ ] night
uh but my cousin now i shouldn't laugh
but but uh
we we used to [ __ ] with him a little bit
because what we'd go over and see him at
christmas me both my brothers and then
my three cousins who were his kids we
would go to my aunts in
highlandtown in baltimore city and then
we would take him like a plate of food
and we'd get over there and we would be
smoking and drinking and stuff and then
he would call on our ride back and rat
us out and say those kids were over here
smoking and you know
drinking and smoking weed and we're like
this [ __ ] so we get back and our
grandmother and her sister you know
yelling at us and all we always would
say you really you don't believe a
paranoid schizophrenic over us like we
were not [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] so then
we go back over like look [ __ ]
if you ever want to eat again you don't
rat us out and i used to go spend time
with him
and he would swear
that doctors were coming in at night and
dropping liquid acid in his ears and
then taking skin grafts and stuff from
him so he would nail his windows shut
but still somehow they would get in
and he would have poetry and [ __ ]
written all over the walls because he
said when these doctors would come in
and drop liquid acid in his ears it
would knock him out and then they would
leave and he'd still be out for a while
and the love of his life would show up
and because he couldn't be conscious to
tell her what he wanted to tell her he
wrote this stuff up on the walls for her
so that's what i mean by never coming
back i'm not coming back i can't have
anything give me this stuff sure why not
you got to take a chance columbus
that's not coming back man
sometimes you don't come back you do
three [ __ ] hits you go home by
yourself the lights don't work you're
sitting in the dark you see the [ __ ]
devil
you see the devil that's what we talk
about seeing the devil i went to his
house one time when he was i don't know
what he was on but he had the television
on volume down radio on volume up
and i sat there for a while and all of a
sudden it synced up and i got scared and
i was like i felt like crazy was you
know contagious it was jumping on me and
i got the [ __ ] out of there when it made
sense when that radio synced up with
that tv you know like the wizard of oz
pink floyd thing we just watched that
last night with the kids do you ever you
ever do that no no so the second mgm
line right
there and it [ __ ] sinks up incredibly
but
whether that's a huge coincidence or
supposed to uh is one thing but when it
does
if that's an accident you're watching
that on any kind of [ __ ] drug i to me
i was like i got the [ __ ] out of here
this guy i think i'm getting crazy in
this little goddamn apartment
i love that
i remember watching
the exorcist yeah on the thc crystal in
the dark with black sabbath master
reality on
and almost going i'm going to i'm going
to hell this is as dark as it [ __ ]
gets
i i never really like i said i never
really had a bad trip i laughed
that's what i wanted to ask you what's
the worst trip you've ever i'll tell you
guys and you know this is us talking and
the people listening to the podcast i
ain't right i ain't right i ain't right
mentally that's what makes me [ __ ]
nuts that's what makes me
half the reason why i got this is
because
i did ask for a year and a half straight
after my mom oh i did it what do you
mean daily i did it
daily daily how many hits a day
you see how i eat edibles
i had my acid tolerance up to like my
edible times are you serious i was going
to [ __ ] pennsylvania and buying 100
hits for 90 bucks and sell them for
three bucks a piece i got up to the
point i was doing four or five hundred
[ __ ] hits a week plus black beauties
for her
for nothing not me
oh okay
i would go every day in the afternoon
like i would just eat them at night and
then we started eating two at night
you know and then you start eating three
at night and one afternoon you're like
let's play hooky and let's eat one at
lunch time
and then you eat two at lunch time and
you get [ __ ] by four o'clock when
you're 16. and i went on that for a
while i just after my mom did i went on
that black sabbath uh you know
that whole thing and that was
what we were doing we were just doing
acid it was the cross between cocaine
cocaine was showing up but we were still
holding dearly the acid because it was
three [ __ ] bucks
i loved it i did it for probably two
years straight man damn at a place when
i was really dark
you know it's when my mom died so at
that point i really didn't care i didn't
want to feel [ __ ] normal so i just
did acid and i thought if i would do
acid and listen to black sabbath at
night with the earphones on
i would listen to sides and i would cure
whatever was going on with me it was the
weirdest thing that was my psychiatry
was doing two hits acid and listening to
[ __ ] aerosmith [ __ ] rocks and
aerosmith toy uh kings and queens that
was my [ __ ]
therapy so
so i
i'm [ __ ] up partly because that's why
i do stand up there's got to be some
connection there they go into my mind
but who wants to do that mind your
business
you want to go [ __ ] electrodes and
[ __ ]
do what i do because i do it right or
wrong who gives a [ __ ] 10 hits ass i
don't know
i never [ __ ] threw somebody off a
building you know i never did nothing
violent and stupid like that or to
yourself no no no no no no no no no no
that's not my [ __ ] game man that
could never that's not even my dna
that's a lot of acid to do to never have
a bad trip too
i know people have done it four times
and one of the and usually the last ones
the one they stopped because it wasn't a
good time well can you have a good trip
and still have moments where i bet that
are bad because like i i didn't have a
bachelor but i had some times that were
like i got too high
sometimes it gets away from you that's
what it's called is that what it's
called it's called getting away from you
it's called
you know when you do very strong acid
let me tell you what happens leaving you
do a very strong asset we're having a
conversation right now right
and all of a sudden as you're talking to
me
your mind goes somewhere else
but you're going to focus on that clint
eastwood and his mouth's going to start
moving
he's not going to say nothing you're not
going to jump you're not going to run
and tell him
you're just going to look at it and suck
it in that means it's getting away from
you
then you take some breath you realize
where you're at you pick up that joint
you take a hit off that joint you put it
back and it calms you down a little bit
that's what i was saying to you you know
it does get away from you i i there was
one night in particular
where i had a
not a bad trip
but it was one of the nights i kind of
blacked out on acid
i was uh
a freshman in high school
and my scene my high school had won the
state championship
and they played at the meadowlands
football football
wait what's the high school the high
school i texted you the picture of yeah
yeah
okay
and on the way back
i went to where the acid neighborhood
was joe lucci's neighborhood their 64th
street field
what's up joe lucci joe lucci had a bar
next to venerie's funeral parlor
when we were kids listen joe lucci
soldiers and move to orlando florida
that sounds crooked just sounds crooked
oh this is tremendous
joe lucha and me shared the same
birthday
so we used to call you used to call me
coco bud
if you wanted to get down
like you know what's that line that he
says eric clapton if you want to get
down get down to the ground cocaine
if you wanted to dick around with people
like joe lucci was joe lucci like when
you got acid from
uh you know brian sickler okay yeah oh
it's red dragon acid but that same acid
was sold by joe lucci
that was [ __ ] highly recommended like
joe lucci didn't [ __ ] around
if joe lucci had a party and you were
invited to that party you were a
professional you could not go to joe
lucci's party and get drunk on three
beers you could not go to joe lucy's
party if you went to joe lucy's party
you went to joe luigi's party because
you knew you were doing blow
you were doing coke you were doing
whatever was there this is these were
the nuts this was 64th street field
you know timmy holloway's listening i'll
have him call in next week this was it
there was kennedy school there was
mckinley school there was franklin
school
there was [ __ ] robert fulton there
was uh horace mann there was the one in
guttenberg everybody had their
reputations every school had different
reputations they're up there their
drinkers up there that's a big football
school
64th street field had the reputation
that when you went down there you went
down to get down
you didn't get down to the [ __ ] around
at all it was called the rocks
they had the rocks down there you went
down to the [ __ ] rocks what does that
mean when you went to a concert in new
york city you saw
different neighborhoods getting
represented like if you went to see
black sabbath you see like kennedy
school had three or four people from
kennedy school mckinley had three people
franklin had three people but the rock
sent 20 [ __ ]
deep [ __ ] with [ __ ] radios and and
[ __ ] black sabbath t-shirts and
running down the street to new york and
yelling they were the [ __ ] crazy kids
in north bergen so when you went to
[ __ ] joe lucci event like i [ __ ]
passed out of the joe lucci party i was
god after that
like when you pass out of the joe lychee
party you're god after that i had blow
in my pocket i was eating quaaludes i
got there like a time you say eating
nuts oh my god i was eating [ __ ]
quaaludes i was drinking those nips
those eight ounce bottles of
budweiser ponies what happens is when
you do blow and you drink you drink a
lot but once you eat the gorilla biscuit
it slows you down what's a gorilla
oh okay so the alcohol catches up with
you so now the alcohol hits you double
so i passed out at lucy's i turned green
they were gonna drag me that's like
speed that's speedball [ __ ] up i got
really [ __ ] up in a joe lucci thing
but
anytime you party at a lucci event
you knew you had it going on like that
was it you were professional they
wouldn't have you over there you would
drink anything i don't drink i'm
gluten-free now
you couldn't show when you went to joe
lucci you were in
whatever they were serving there was no
holding back he had broads over there
it was a great place to grow up and his
father had a bar
so when we were kids we were hands off
the bar but then as we got older we'd go
into the bar and he took over the bar
when the bar
when cocaine was huge so it was electric
and he had a back room
and on saturday nights if you knew of
certain people at any time tonight you
could go around the back and knock on
the door and somebody would answer that
being there [ __ ] getting down
and the dude who took me in after john
bender was a guy by the name of mike
running
and he used to smoke marlborough lights
but him and his three brothers the whole
family has a thing and when they do a
line of coke you've never seen anything
like that their jaw
goes that's cut with speed [ __ ] no no no
no no this wasn't cocaine was cocaine
anything they did
their jaw
just you never skies
guys you've never ever seen this the
whole family the whole five of them when
i was a sears family photo they do
now when i was a kid there was a guy by
the name of jack finn who was an irish
dude from weehawken that worked at
randall lumber with me and that was the
first time ever i saw somebody twitch
when they do coke
and he would just move his hands that's
how you know he was doing coke he would
do this [ __ ] in front of you lee
yeah so how you doing everything all
right you're like what is wrong with his
[ __ ] hand
and he would twitch that's the first guy
i ever seen do it you know who else i
saw do a twitch my mom when i was a kid
my mom would twitch at the end of the
night her hand would do something funny
and she would see this blow so i knew
that i knew the mannerisms do you ever
twitch i oh yeah i twitched uh my face
would go but i never saw
i had i saw then i saw who else
i saw that that the guy twitching but
then mike ronnie came along
mike mike ronnie's like my brother we
we had him call into the podcast he told
the story about throwing the hooker out
of the car
so mike ronnie's weakness like funny
weakness
was as soon as he'd do a line of coke
his [ __ ] jaw would go i mean
embarrassing girl like if
like it was and he tried to talk to you
he put a cigarette in his mouth to try
and disguise it
and he'd be chomped out of the city
and he'd look at every once in a while
go coax is my joke going and you tell
them that you're fine don't worry about
that
meanwhile teeth and blood are just
coming out of its mouth
i remember one night my friend goes
listen i'm having a party
but my kids are going to be there in my
family no coke until they leave
i'll never forget this this is this is
this
this is september of 93.
my friend goes i'm having a party i want
everybody to show up but listen no coke
till 10 o'clock 10 30 to my family at
least i go nope you know me dog i don't
need to do [ __ ]
open bar [ __ ] tremendous food anger
with cliffs looking over the george
washington bridge
we all get there mike ronnie gets there
he's watching this [ __ ] tv set
you know like everybody's in the circle
but i see mike all the way on the other
side of the room by himself
watching the tv set and i walk up to him
he's got a cigarette in his mouth and
he's [ __ ] grinding
i go mike venery said not to do any [ __ ]
to his family that he looks at me goes
i didn't do nothing
but this particular night
i'll never forget this particular night
lucci's and timmy was there i think
somebody said they went and the power
went
and that they didn't know what was going
on but all of a sudden they looked and
they saw a cigarette
going from side to side in the dark
so i used to call him the conductor
because his [ __ ]
i never saw another
[ __ ] hysterical oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
hysterical so i don't you know like
my point is that all this drug talk is i
just don't
i don't want to drive from drugs no i
never wanted to die from drugs
for years i didn't you know i thought
when you're doing drugs you think you're
invincible jesus christ
i don't listen things happen in life i
don't want somebody finding me on the
floor because i took three hits ass and
had a heart attack in the middle of the
[ __ ] night you know you're sitting
there you get sucked into a dream your
heart's beating sometimes you go into a
wild dream you're getting chased by
devils and [ __ ] your heart beats like
well don't say that i'll have that now
yeah
what we're gonna do is we're gonna give
two hits away to a friend and we're
gonna keep three
just for us one night before the years
old we'll come in we'll split it in half
just me and you and wait like ten you
just said you're glad we didn't take
more than one and now you're adding
halfway here's a [ __ ] you know
every once in a while you gotta
contradict yourself that's what makes
you who the [ __ ] you are
but yeah but joe's lucci's neighborhood
that's where you went to get down those
guys
got down
i've been thinking a lot about that
neighborhood the last couple of weeks
because a friend of mine died
i remember taking a hit of acid and
going down the shore in a bus
with this kid named randy murgle who was
white and tougher than [ __ ] nails
tougher than nails on this kid the
agostino who wasn't as tough as nails
but he just was crazy
and he had a boom box and we were
listening to highway to hell on the
radio on the cassette deck and the bus
driver had to kept pulling over yelling
pull that [ __ ] thing down and we're
dripping on [ __ ] acid
and that's the closest i ever came to
death
because we took another hit of acid and
we all decided to meet on the water
slide and seaside
midnight
a turned off water slide at an amusement
park no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no it's oh still it's like it's
open till four in the morning oh
something [ __ ] oh okay so what did so
you're not breaking into the music no no
so what you do is you do whatever you do
like i'd say ryan what are you going to
do tonight i'm going to meet some
chicken have some cocktails i go ryan
come here take this at the house and
meet the girls are you going to [ __ ]
them no no they're just friends of my
sister all right perfect go hang out
with them but meet us back here at
midnight you know how much fun that is
when you have something to do when
you're burning when you're cooking and
you have something to do then it's great
because even if we take the ass at eight
at midnight we're gonna meet 12 [ __ ]
gorillas and you know
let our head down you know what i'm
saying
but i'm happy you don't do it i don't
listen like i said i just
i don't want uh
let your your heart only has enough
beats
you said that your heart when when god
makes you he's like this guy's gonna
have 82 million [ __ ] beats do the
math however you get there is your
decision whether you want to do blow and
get there or you want to do jumping
jacks you want to eat ass that's your
[ __ ] decision
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do lee
you're going gonna sit there and just
like a boat to like what's going on with
you
yeah everybody's conversing here yeah
and you're [ __ ] sitting there like a
mook on a [ __ ] stream what's going on
i never did coke
i don't know
oh my gosh i have no idea what we were
talking about all right let me give some
shout outs
jonathan hernandez jesse wright
alex bisson jt you know i love you
[ __ ] scott ghosting colton damo
k ron conlon and the other voices there
you have it [ __ ]
got a little shout out there for you
it's not about the coke i'm just saying
anything in general man you know you do
a little [ __ ] ecstasy you don't know
what's going to happen
now ecstasy is the one that's mixed with
heroin and the mdma is the one that's
just straight i believe so i don't think
xcc has heroin in it yeah i mean it's
mixed it's
cut with a lot of different [ __ ] i'm
sure opiates
for sure in there heroin opium i like
any of it i had um
i remember i was going to get a
prescription for uh a refill of percocet
i have a tear in one of my discs in my
back and the doctor's like you need to
take it and
it makes me uh itch like a crackhead you
know i start sweating i throw up from it
like i really i need to snap him in half
and that usually is enough to kill the
pain and not make me sick
so i'm in there for a refill and i
smoked up and i went into writing i'm
standing in line and i'm not thinking
about it but i'm standing there and all
these people in line i got my hand up my
shirt and i'm just crazy digging my
chest
and i don't realize
every i'm in a drugstore [ __ ]
prescription line i'm just going nuts on
and they're all turned around looking at
me and it didn't dawn on me what i was
doing until about the third person was
you know looking back like this guy have
a [ __ ] problem that we're in line
with right now have you ever encountered
that i was at a
like a rite aid in van nuys and this
dude was trying to get them to give them
needles
and they wouldn't do it
and he kept saying he kept like yelling
at them
and and how the government took
everything away from him and they just
give him the needles he called the
doctor and they just wouldn't give it to
him why wouldn't they they're supposed
to give you needles for free syringes
for free well maybe no maybe it wasn't
on prescriptions i'm sorry yeah he's
crying for a [ __ ] prescription
because the doctor yeah the pain yeah
hey listen man that [ __ ] you get
addicted on those things
you're [ __ ] done you know and
everybody knows that [ __ ] we've been
hearing it for years like anything else
it's like [ __ ] anything else man josh
adam myers told me one time that he went
into a rite aid with a fake script to
get some percocets or whatever when he
came back
the the [ __ ] farmers just caught him
up to the front
and as brought him up and he said
because you know josh wrote a fake name
on it and the the pharmacist called him
out in front of everybody said this man
right here used a fake prescription
to get pills if i ever see you in here
again mr oral herscheiser i will have
you arrested that the [ __ ] used
aurora architezer in los angeles as his
name
thought he'd get away with that [ __ ]
that's ridiculous well that's the
addiction i thought i'll get right
josh adam is a lot smarter than that
it's the [ __ ] addiction that takes
you over the [ __ ] top
i was never a fake prescription guy
i used to get scripts with some from
everything when i was younger so all i
had to do was ask the guy and bring him
again grandma coke
and then you would get whatever whatever
i want
pills don't have the same effect on you
what's that pills don't have the same
effect on this coke
and i don't know i like a valium from
time i just don't like waking up rocky
there's nothing that bothers me
i could eat
[ __ ] 300 milligrams of thc
and wake up feeling like i [ __ ] got a
massage the night before
never mind you eat hash you eat a piece
of hash before you go to bed you see
what you feel like in the morning
you feel like you've been stepped down
all night you feel like you're [ __ ]
gumby in the morning yeah i don't like
happiness but too heavy it's but
but if you eat it
it does something to your body man yeah
it's [ __ ] amazing
i'll take i'll tell you what kills me
those town rpms oh god you wake up
feeling like dick in the morning you
wake up feeling like
something synthetic
which is a horrible feeling and unless
you've been a junkie you know that i've
never been a junkie but i've been a
junkie i know what it's like when
something doesn't feel right
something that like cody i was never a
coding guy
any of that [ __ ] makes me some guy yeah
it makes my stomach hurt
right up i got dizzy i give them to
people i got a little bit addicted to
the tyler 1pm my first semester of
college and what did you feel like in
the morning
i still but i slept till two i felt okay
if i still got that much sleep if i
could sleep till two if i had like a
lady right you gotta sleep 12 hours but
then the thing is i couldn't sleep
without it and i i couldn't not sleep in
school so i had to i like waited until i
had a long weekend or something to get
off of them and get back on the sleep
schedule like if i didn't take them for
a while i would just wouldn't sleep
so i can't like
that like that's why i love doing these
animals
no i don't i can't see feeling that
shitty in the morning
my friend gave me 0.5 volumes and he's
right when he gets home there's nights
i'm going to do comedy i'm gonna leave
like last night
i had to leave in the middle of night i
slept four [ __ ] hours last night when
i was leaving minneapolis so yesterday
in the afternoon
after breakfast about eleven i pop a
point five
i watched saturday whatever the [ __ ] i
was telling you guys
and at the point that they went to the
guy's house to get the girl back i shut
it off belly hills cop i shut it off i
took a two and a half hour little
[ __ ] siesta i woke up i put a little
coffee together in my room i drank a cup
of coffee i roll a little bit and then i
want to lift the [ __ ] weights for an
hour that two hours of that little nap
that thing saves me a [ __ ]
ton of
i went to my room last night when i got
off stage not even when i [ __ ] i ate
my little 0.5 valium before i even got
paid last night
i put my check in my pocket i took
pictures of people i went to my room
last night i drank some water i was
already packed i shut the lights off at
12 30. next thing i know my phone was
ringing it was five in the [ __ ]
morning that's how i wrote man i love
those little [ __ ] things but i won't
get
hooked on them i slept this afternoon
without them you know i'll space them
out i'll eat them on the road when i'm
home i don't need [ __ ] because i'm
working out a little bit more i'm
walking a little bit more so i'm more
[ __ ] tired i'm talking for this
[ __ ] good nook on the phone what's
the matter with you lee
nothing you're all [ __ ] up today
what's the matter we didn't give you
nothing
at least telling the truth
i'm good man
this is hitting me hard it's hitting
your heart what do you got going on
tarzan so are you doing the podcast
again is your partner back yeah uh he
just had a baby girl his second baby and
uh we're back to recording now you have
the crab feast you can check us out on
all things comedy and
itunes and the crabfeast.com and you go
on the road a lot of no not a lot no but
i'm i'll be in st louis actually uh
go to ryancichler.com my date's on there
i think it's friday the 6th something
like that i'm going to go
i'm at a place called um
jesus christ this is christ it's uh
blueberry hill blueberry hill i'm down
at blueberry hill friday uh
i'm headlining that show and there's a
couple local guys are going to be up on
the bill too and what's blueberry hill a
bar
yeah it's a bar down in uh like the
square i think down in st louis you've
been to st louis i've been there before
i'm there in february at helium they're
opening up they're open oh yeah i think
it's open already
you might as well go to the [ __ ]
helium telling you [ __ ]
i'm in town to do a benefit show
saturday and i
i always like to get in town early and
do my own show
before i go do that because i can't you
know i got to do 20 minutes of clean
material i can't do what i want to do
friday night how many kids you got two
how old
my uh stepson is 12 and my daughter just
turned one
a few days ago and how's deception
working with you you're talking awesome
yeah we're tight and he loves his little
sister she loves him yeah we're good you
know he's he's a typical i i don't have
any trouble with him outside of him
being a typical 12 year old boy who's
you know seventh grade starting to come
into his own and think he's the [ __ ]
does he have a relationship with his dad
he has a relationship with his dad but
his dad
doesn't see him much maybe once or twice
a month and it's a saturday and bring
him back sunday or usually takes him out
to his his parents his grandparents who
i actually have a relationship with i'll
go drop them off up there
but i'm
every day in the house you know i'm the
dad there you know it's like a couple
months ago i was really adamant
about connecting with my daughter we
talked about this i remember and uh the
more i think about it it's like i'm done
i'm out i i really uh
i just heard different things from
different people
and
i'd never wanted to be that guy like i
didn't want to show up in aspen and
knock on her door
and tell her whatever the [ __ ] i got to
tell her and then
a year from now
she catches me one day when i'm in a
half a mood
and i tell her exactly what i feel
and uh
i don't know i just
these are the reasons why
it's a [ __ ] horror story getting
divorced in this country
it's a [ __ ]
it is i know so many people going
through it
you know especially here in california
it's a no-fault state and if you're
married for 10 years
then you owe alimony for life
10 years for life so you can move in
like let's say let's say you're a woman
you're the breadwinner
and your husband cheats on you
and you get a divorce you owe him
alimony and he can have another woman
move in your house and as long as he
doesn't marry her you still gotta pay
his ass alimony it's so [ __ ] crooked
it's so wrong
uh but it is a harsh that's a third of
it
you're right about that what happens
with the kids
and the parents detachment is something
that
had me [ __ ] up for years i can't lie
to anybody it really really had me
snorting whatever excuse i wanted to
make i'm not that type of guy that i'd
be crying but just the pain of it just
uh
you know i had a child snatch from me
snatched however it was done it was done
legally illegally i fed into it and then
i bought into it you know
and i bought into the notion that i was
just interfering
i know what it's like to have an
interference
they were trying to put a family
together you know i was somebody who had
at five o'clock they had to stop what
they were doing to come meet me to come
pick up their child and then know what
the [ __ ] they were gonna expect and then
every other sunday and then there was my
situation so what do i do here i'm i'm
this [ __ ] crazy coke guy that's
trying to become a comedian
and on wednesdays from two to five i
stop my life from two to seven and i
have this five-year-old girl which i
know nothing about raising a
five-year-old girl except you give him
love and you spoil him and you tell him
you love him or whatever and i was doing
that wrong according to them you know
what i'm saying so i felt like i was
just interfering
i wanted to be a part of her life
not some guy that showed up two days a
[ __ ] week and had no say at all in
her life that's just an interference
that's a [ __ ] uncle that's a [ __ ]
uncle you know what i'm saying i didn't
want to go down as that [ __ ] uncle
and now i i i think about and i go what
do i gain what do i gain now what do i
gain
what do i feel i'm contacting her what
do i gain
what the [ __ ] do i gain i gain
nothing
i gain what a face what do i gain uh
what are you looking for i'm not looking
for anything i don't know what i'm
looking for anyway i mean if she
contacted me do i love it or death yeah
do i want the best fighter yes
but what can i do at this point
i know guys how old is she she's 25 26
and listen i'm not [ __ ] i'm not i'm
not a genius but i know at some point i
got to tell my story and i don't want to
tell my story
i don't want to tell my
story i don't think it's necessary for
her to know it i don't i don't want it
to go out that way
when i write the book i'm going to put a
chapter in there about what happened my
opinion of what happened
you know that's my side of what happened
and what i felt at the time what was
happening
you know i didn't give up a comedy i
don't give up easily i don't give up
easily but i knew in that relationship
and that part of my life i was going
nowhere i was gonna have a child
10 hours every other week guys
10 hours every other week
that's nothing that's uh what are those
people that visit you when you don't
have a dad yeah big brother
a [ __ ] big brother that's what i
wanted to be a big [ __ ] brother with
no say and people telling me i was
always wrong and i was you know
but couldn't it also being great like
there has to be a possibility there was
no possibility at that time not then but
i'm saying now like if we continue with
it
i think when you're ready to hear her
story you'll be ready to tell your story
that's that if and when that happens
that's what it'll be i gotta be that's
all it can be yeah i got a bad story
right
i'm not talking about her past excuse me
her past story
i'm talking about her current and future
story like if you're ready to hear that
if
then you'll be ready to share yours
because that's the only way you're going
to be able to get that
you know what i'm saying
i mean you keep talking you've mentioned
it a couple of times so i know you're
there's something in you it's not
curious about
it i mean i don't mean to be rude and i
hope this doesn't come off poorly but
both of you have parents who passed away
like don't like
doesn't don't anything like her even
though she's gonna be really mad at you
don't you think she's like when you guys
have wanted like even though you might
have been mad at your mother from dying
early
when you wanted her to come back
it just seems
like it could be pretty awesome
i just leave
there's so much
[ __ ] [ __ ]
listen she's a 25 year old kid all right
i had a great relationship with her up
to a point
and then i had to live my life i had to
i had to find out who the [ __ ] and what
i was gonna do with my life i couldn't
sit there
and be this person i really wasn't
i was doing blow four nights a week i
was living off returns
i was living off returns i was living
like a [ __ ] pimp eating three meals a
day out
living on returns bringing back espresso
machines and carpets and cars lawn
mowers whatever i could walk into that
[ __ ] uh customer service with i
picked it up a toaster whatever the [ __ ]
it was sandals whatever the [ __ ] got me
100 bucks for the day and i had 19 malls
to choose from from wyoming all the way
up to denver and i'd start all over
again you know
that that that's how i was making a
living i was if i wasn't doing that i
was working at the sports betting
service which i was getting high four
nights a [ __ ] week that's why i was
doing my money i couldn't have been a
dad in reality
i couldn't have been a dad to myself i
was sleeping two hours a [ __ ] day i
would get it on wednesdays and have to
get chinese food on the arm
you know that chinese ron yeah no that's
before romney after ron the other guy
there was just a thousand stories but
there was love there and i was trying to
do something
i was trying to do something you know
what i'm saying i was never going to get
the chance to [ __ ] accomplish it not
by their
not with their [ __ ] brow beatings we
were going to be in court once a month
you know what would it cost you to go to
court once a month
yeah money three four thousand [ __ ]
biggest racket right come on guys i was
getting killed here dragging that [ __ ]
so i don't want to tell my story she's
gonna come with a story she's gonna tell
me why she hasn't contacted me there's a
reason why she hasn't raised her hand
there's a reason guys okay something was
told
that there's a reason why she's not
raising the hand and it was told by a
mother and a grandfather i know how this
racket works
so and i don't want to go back and forth
with nobody not at this age i got a
second chance
i got a second chance i'm gonna go back
and try to [ __ ] redo history listen i
got a thousand question marks in my life
i would love to go back for a week to
new york city and go to weehawken union
city and find out the name of my mom's
businesses and what name of a license
she got on and you know what was left
over the reason why she sold all that
stuff i would love to have time to
[ __ ] find all that [ __ ] out but what
would i do what i'm living right now
what would i i got a thousand things on
my plate right now i just can't put them
away because i want to dig up a [ __ ]
cold case
yeah i want to find out what the [ __ ]
happened you know
where were you thinking
you know i reach out to people from time
to time man
and i'll tell you it hurts my feelings
they don't even contact me back
you know i'm a big believer in therapy
i've gone to therapy quite uh often and
uh one of the things
that i learned
uh and i you know i
i don't have a relationship with my
mother and we because we had a bad one
it wasn't that we had none we had a bad
one
her leading the way
and um
i don't know how long ago was maybe
eight years ago
i decided
that i was just going to forgive her i
was going to forgive her for i wasn't
speaking for the family i wasn't a
representative for my father or my
brothers this was me
talking for me and me only
and i called her and
she was blown away and uh
you know and she's like you know you
hate me and i said listen over the years
i've learned a few things and and this
is my own opinion of it but in order to
love someone you have to have a strong
positive relationship with them in order
to hate someone i believe you have to
have a strong negative relationship with
them i think there needs to be a
relationship
for hate
and the fact is i don't know you you
don't know me you don't know my favorite
color you don't know what i like to eat
you don't know anything and she's just
crying you know and i'm like so i don't
hate you because i don't know you i
really don't even know who you are but i
forgive you
and
nothing changed nothing changed and then
i felt like a fool for doing it you know
and i was talking to one of my
therapists and one of the truest things
that i've heard is that you can't
forgive
someone who isn't asking for forgiveness
this woman wasn't asking me to be
forgiven it's something i was offering
to make myself feel better
ultimately and it backfired it didn't
change it didn't do anything and you
know if someone's not coming to you and
saying hey i'm sorry i'm asking for
forgiveness i you know can you forgive
me for this and calling themselves out
then they don't really think they did
anything wrong so
you're offering them something that
they're not buying they're not
interested in they're not whatever
that's a thing for you and then i
realized that you know in hindsight and
i was like god because it did it burned
me it made me feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and a fool for a minute but you
know
i tried something and it didn't work and
you know
it is what it is at this point i forgave
one of the biggest pains i had in my
life
i forgave my stepdad i don't know why i
don't so this day i wrestle with it back
and forth
you know what he did to me between 79
to 85 was just amazing what we were back
and forth you know and there's people
there's two sides to every story
and i even compromised by myself i i
said you know i was looking for money
i was saying what what the [ __ ] happened
to my mom's money you know
there's a house there's this there's
that and he's like well the other side
there's a half a million dollars in debt
you don't know about that i knew about i
knew that that was legit you know
and i had painted the drugs and the pain
had painted this picture that had this
money owed to me
and it created this person inside of me
i was gonna kill him
so for years when i went to colorado in
83 was to let the situation cool down
and for me to come back and kill him
that was it that was a situation
that was it yeah very plain and simple
do you like a timeline at that time that
was where my head was at
i like how you were letting it cool down
to return to kill someone oh no it was
hard to think it would be camped out i
mean listen
my mom died yes i took one of the things
out there and i had a party in the house
but he locked me out of there he la he
changed the locks i was never allowed to
go into my childhood home again there
was no social security i mean the list
went on and on
and he added to it by not helping out
but i didn't want his help in a way i
hurt his feelings when i decided to move
with somebody other than him
you know he i think he would have helped
me if i would have moved him there's a
lot of back and forth here but the
bottom line is that i spoke to a friend
of mine that i grew up with about it six
months ago and she goes that she goes
you know that before
he died and my mom died they didn't
speak for about six years
and i go really that's weird i didn't
know that she goes yeah because one
night he came over
and my mom went off on him for not
helping you
and i go in your heart do you really
think that he should help me
and she goes everybody believes
he should have helped you
and deep down inside i know i know this
i'm the type of guy i'm not [ __ ] that
dumb i knew he should have gave me 30
000 and set me up and you know just just
by what my mom had done for him
and uh
i was [ __ ] really mad man
and an 85 i came back in 84
and i had the thoughts going back and
forth but people were like you know what
you want to stay away from at this point
in his life and i was doing my own
craziness and i left in 85 and i came
back in 91 and i went up there looking
for him and we talked and we both looked
at it from a different perspective
he never gave me a dime
he never gave me a dime i forgave him
but there's moments once twice a month
that i can't believe that this guy
because at the end he left like a
million dollars
and then i went to his house i spoke to
his ex-wife
his wife at the time i went over there
and i thought she would go in the room
and at least give me my father's jewelry
and she took that jewelry and that cash
and then she got diagnosed with cancer
and then her brother got the cash then
he got diagnosed with cancer jesus you
don't want them no that's what i'm
saying
that money was poisoned from the start
so in a way i always thought that i
would get it later on in my life
something would happen that that money
would come to me in a different light
you know what i'm saying that's how i
let that
i forgave them in a way when it comes to
my ex-wife
jacqueline's mother jackie ball's mother
a dog i don't see it at all
i don't see it at all from a catholic
to a human being
i don't see it at all
as as lee as my friend
and you're a great guy
i could never sit here like a regular
[ __ ] american
and tell you that i could forgive him
you have no idea the thoughts that come
to my mind even today if you had to
guess what would you say
she was gonna say you did like why was
she so angry
she probably talked a lot about the
kidnapping
you know she probably said a lot about
he's a kidnapper he did this and that
she probably uh
you know just told that that
and no way listen she told her the truth
i was out of my [ __ ] mind you know
what i'm saying but she forgot to tell
the other truth that i really loved this
child that this child was the only
family i had in the [ __ ] world
you know this was everything i had this
was it
when she came home and said she want to
get a divorce i was fine with it i
understand that people don't last
forever but i was also sold to bill a
lady that said that i was going to have
a relationship with this child full time
and then i was like then one day she
just moved out of her parents house
without telling me moved her into a
guy's house
that right there
is grounds for [ __ ] chopping your
head off yeah
why come from that right there is
grounds for chopping your [ __ ] head
off
i was paying everything i had i used to
pick the child up at daycare and walking
back to my place then she'd pick her up
and then one day i would call her at
night let me say goodbye night to jackie
uh they're not here what the [ __ ] you
mean and the mother was
uh that's why i never really talked to
the mother again because the mother was
in the middle of everything and i
understood she felt bad whatever
but i've never i can never see me
forgiving
jackie's mother
and i put that out publicly
it was just too much
it's still too much
i've called three times and had her just
to call me back and i just want to say i
love and i was thinking about it oh
jackie's busy
she just went through a relationship and
she's still mourning my
father who died two years ago so she
can't pick up a [ __ ] phone
so i don't know what they're telling
them i guarantee all the gifts i sent
and everything nothing was ever given to
her all the letters i sent nothing was
ever given to her i guarantee nothing i
guarantee everything was dodged and
thrown away and they told her i never
sent anything so
these are the things i know that you
know
i know she probably told her about the
drugs
you know that's for damn sure
but i meant more online like you as a
husband
like like why would she be mad at you
i let it down dawg
a woman has a dream
not every woman but most women have a
dream
that someday
the [ __ ] quarterback's gonna [ __ ]
propose to them
you know a woman wants security
you know
one thing i am guilty of in this whole
thing it was i was a shitty husband
you're rightly
i got married for the wrong reasons i
got mad i was young i had no idea what
marriage was
or [ __ ] relationship
i got married because i knocked a woman
up
you know
which pro and con i can't support or not
support it at least i gave it a try
it just didn't work i was a horrible
husband lately because i didn't know
what a husband was
how old were you when you got married
23 oh god
that would have been terrible 24 25 you
know doesn't really matter i wasn't
ready for it i didn't know what the [ __ ]
it was
i didn't know what you had to feel for
somebody when i look at my wife terry
now and i look in the kitchen stand i
still love them more than ever
i love terry more than [ __ ] ever you
know
until i went to kiss her and the baby
was there and the baby pushed her away
from me stopped
no problem
no no what'd she say today she said
something clay she was very funny to her
today we both left the house [ __ ]
laughing
but that was tonight in the kitchen i
went to kiss my wife
and she stepped right in there stop
stop
what do you got planned this weekly
what's happening i'm going to [ __ ]
fort lauderdale to the improv my dad's
excited i know it's four days to dickie
[ __ ] saya does dick cyan have a car
yeah dick sciatt might be giving me a
[ __ ] ride
you're going to be you're on a mission
from [ __ ] satan i throw them a couple
yards
i'm about to go to deep into miami
i do i do have to go deep into miami
either [ __ ] wednesday night
i want to do it thursday in the daytime
so i'm thinking of doing is getting back
to my room
taking a shower eating a nice dinner and
then taking a [ __ ] car down to miami
hanging out miami for two three hours i
see these people
let them do that thing and then i go
back to my room and everything's
beautiful i wake up in the morning take
a shower and i'm out of it you know what
i'm saying
i really gotta go see these people i
grew up with man that'd be excited
i'm always excited i'm always excited to
go on the road you know that i hate the
[ __ ] daughter and i hate the whole
thing i was thinking about lee driving
me this week because i got to be there
at
like eight in the morning that's a
shitty time to fly at
i like flying out at five six
eight o'clock i gotta [ __ ] drive in
traffic on wednesday god
damn it
but you know what man once you're on
stage thursday night it's a [ __ ] good
time
that's at least i am yeah i'm working
i'm [ __ ] working ryan
how many [ __ ] comedians this is why
you get into this
you get into this to finally for people
who want to go see and people want to
talk to you and they want to buy a shirt
they want to talk to you about [ __ ]
lee or whatever this is why you do this
i have the opportunity this is why i do
this now i hate when people call me for
stupid auditions now you're not going to
get me to audition on a thursday and
cancel now i got an investment now i
want to go on thursday night to see
these people there's a hundred [ __ ]
50 people are coming on thursday with
joints and it's a acid for leaves and
[ __ ] like that
what the [ __ ] man
let's do some [ __ ] sponsors and we'll
get the [ __ ] out of here right people
listen your time is precious and you
want to feed your mind with the best of
what's out there but who's the hell's
got time to sit through all the nonsense
on the internet for those who for those
of us who want premium content and don't
have time
to waste finding it there's next issue
next issue is a mobile app that lets you
tap directly into the world's most
popular magazines anytime anywhere using
your phone or your tablet
all right iconic magazines they have
like people vogue esquire time and more
and next issue lets you dive deeper into
the story with interactive content for
richer reading experience sign up for
next issue right now you'll get
immediate access access to all the top
magazines including back issues and
exclusive videos and photos
they have the best content around and
the topics that you want most about
listen they got teen vogue sports
illustrator for kids yoga journal
working mother they got us weekly time
the new yorker star sports illustrated
people okay and the list goes on and on
and on do me a favor all right
do me the here's the best thing next
issue is offering you a free trial right
now when you go to next issue dot com
slash joey that's next issue dot com
slash joey all right
again try next issue for free right now
go to next issue dot com slash joey and
you tap into all the magazines that are
going on right now please use it it's a
great app if you travel if you really if
you have any time that you that you're
just like on a train it'd be great
because you can download them you don't
have to be on the internet and they're
like full color
magazines it's not like just the text
because sometimes you go read news
online it'll just be text these are the
full color magazines and some of them
have some like video content with them
it's pretty great and they have back
issues too it's not just like the most
recent one you can go back so you got
runner's world rolling stone you got
food and wine you got the food network
you got fortune you got forbes you got
basically everything on your fingertips
if you fly you download it before you
fly you're sitting there for five hours
like
or you use the wi-fi on the plane do me
a favor go to next issue dot com right
now
all right and go next issue dot com
slash joey and get a free trial offer
right now
that's it that's all i got to tell you
guys also why [ __ ] around you're like
joey you flew today and you're in a good
mood you're all ho-hum you know why
mm-hmm because i took the [ __ ] alpha
brain that's why
that's right and then when i land before
i [ __ ] land i drink a little powder
that would turn around 180. i went home
i took a two-hour nap i ate some pasta
basil and i'm here in a good mood i got
energy you know why [ __ ] uh
honest.com that's what they give you the
best in [ __ ] supplements you
understand me they ain't [ __ ] around
over there from the t booster to the
[ __ ] uh uh the the the swim tech they
should take a sport they'll have forced
protein the cocoa [ __ ] tastes
delicious i mean we're not [ __ ]
around it but do me a favor go to
honor.com right now look at the great
selection of supplements that they have
from the tea supplement to the coconut
oil to dip in your coffee they're doing
it right over that honestly the whole
foods now they ain't [ __ ] around go
to onit.com if you see something like go
to the box and press in church boom get
10 off your first order they also have a
stay on it program that gets delivered
right to your door that saves you time
and money and energy go to honor.com
right now they got a great product okay
number two i want to give a shout out to
my [ __ ] over there
hillysigs.com right now
electronic cigarettes taking it to the
next limit 1200
pups per [ __ ] cigar you know what
that lasts that lasts you a [ __ ]
month right now they're running a deal
five for fifty dollars so you get a
cigar you get a 24 milligram 16 eight
zero i don't know what the [ __ ]
numbers are but who gives a [ __ ] they're
running a deal you can't lose go to
hitting six right now and try out the
cigar at least go to the box and press
in joey's church boom and what do they
get off five or fifty
five for fifty that's what you get
number three
nailedthelife.com you want a vapor pen
that's who you go to right now
nailed it life.com
they got the best vaping pen out there
in the market right now they're running
a special 20 off that used to be 50 that
means it's 40 now all right
do the math why are you bothering me
for california residents they have those
gummies hermanos whether it's uh the
little gummy bear or
the the white chocolate that tastes
delicious ricotta plus they [ __ ] me up
we gave him to rash dude he went missing
for three days go to nailed it life.com
right now and press in joey diaz boom
and get what they got 20 20 off your
vapor pen all right so you got next
issue giving you a free trial offer you
got on it giving you 10 percent off you
got 80 cigs and you got nailed to life
who's better than you i'm very
interested in this next issue this next
issue is a good deal for you guys
especially if you have like a big like a
tablet because it gets bigger or like my
giant phone
okay go to next issue and get your free
trial off all right
besides that i want to thank ryan
sickler for coming in on a sunday night
and [ __ ] around with us i want to
thank my main man lisa for taking her to
the next [ __ ] level
that's it that's all i gotta say
all right